c'est l'histoire à youtube heures qui
vous a parlé de jeu de son enfance qui
vous a ensuite parlé de son adolescence
il qui va aujourd'hui vous parler de son
enfance tout court pourquoi personne
n'est chaud pardonnez ma voix et mes
bref le manche est un peu malade
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de mes
années écoles primaires je vous en
parler parce que j'ai trop d'anecdotes
incroyable plus encore même que quand
j'étais adolescent on va commencer tout
de suite avec l'anecdote la plus débile
de tout j'étais en classe au milieu des
autres élèves et nous étions en cours de
match je n'arrivais plus à me concentrer
car ça me gratte énormément dans
l'oreille gauche
je regarde alors mon crayon je vois en
lui un gros potentiel pour se gratter
l'intérieur de l'oreille mais je
m'aperçois aussi que la gomme et comme
fissurer c'est alors que je me lance un
challenge me gratter l'oreille avec le
côté gomme du crayon sans que la gomme
reste dans mon oreille savoir est je me
suis grattée si fort que le plaisir ce
voyez sur mon visage mais en ressortant
le crayon la gomme n'était plus là elle
était dans mon oreille
c'est alors que j'ai terminé la journée
dans le bureau du proviseur à les
regarder et essayer de me l'enlever avec
une pince à épiler
le lendemain j'ai raté l'école car j'ai
dû aller chez un médecin spécialisé pour
me faire retirer le bout de gomme tout
était prévu depuis je sais pas maman sur
hier cette vidéo
excuse moi la morale de l'histoire c'est
ne vous lancez jamais de challenge que
vous avez entre 7 et 11 ans puisque ça
finit toujours mal
la deuxième fois je me suis lancé un
challenge sais pas pourquoi je me
lançais du challenge c'est complètement
débile mais j'adorais ça quand j'étais
petit j'adorais les bonbons comme tous
les enfants et ma mère comme toutes les
mamans les cacher dans un bocal en verre
posé sur le frigo de manière à ce que je
puisse pas les atteindre ce qu'elle
avait oublié c'est dans un appartement a
aussi des chaises déchets ça rajoute de
la hauteur à ton petit corps de huit ans
je mets une chaise j'atteins le bocal
rempli de bonbons je suis très heureux
et en le tirant vers moi je vous fais
tomber par terre à mes pieds je vous
cache pas dans ma vie j'ai jamais eu
autant de bonbons que ce jour là autour
de moi mais le problème c'est que j'ai
aussi jamais eu autant de bouts de verre
autour de moi et c'est là que le
challenge compte de l'enfant qu'on de
huit ans arrive au quai en descendant
délicatement de cette chaise je peux
faire un petit saut au dessus des bouts
de verre et m'en sortir indemne à la
seconde où je saute de la chaise
j'atterris sur un bout de verre mon pote
il m'a transpercé le bas du gros doigts
de pied et à l'heure actuelle j'ai
encore une plaie à l'époque j'ai eu le
courage de dire maintenant je m'étais
blessé en faisant quelque chose
d'interdît j'avais peur des représailles
vous comprenez du coup je n'ai pas dit
que je m'étais blessé mais mec j'aurais
dû avoir des points de suture et du coup
maintenant son doigt puis il ya un trou
béant aujourd'hui des fois quand je
marche ça me fait mal parce que le
le truc est sec et du coup j'ai passé je
saigne un peu je sais c'est dégueulasse
vraiment tout ça pour des bobos
c'est encore c'était pour des abonnés ou
début je comprendrais mais bon coffre
on a tous vécu à l'école primaire des
situations on s'est sentis immensément
qu'on voire même humilié mon frère et
moi avons cinq ans et demi d'écart ce
qui veut dire que quand je suis arrivé
au cp il quittait le cm2 en quittant le
cm2
j'ai hérité littéralement de toute sa
collection de jouets à la mode parce
qu'ils allaient rien à faire au collège
y aller juste passer pour un gros loser
auprès des 4e 3e qui sont ce qui
t'intéresse quand tu es en sixième à
l'époque la mode c'était pas l'époque
c'était pas les pille c'était les jo jo
ce mon pote les jo jo c'était des petits
monstres qu'il fallait collectionner un
peu comme les cartes pokémon d'acheter
un sachet d'eau douce et tu priais pour
qu'il y ait des dodgers rare de dors mon
frère est en tort chez ce truc pendant
trois ans était le king et john john
hocking de l'école un soir ils m'offrent
son sachet rempli de jo jo y avait des
jo ce brillant mais clé brillance et
qu'ils étaient mes gars je suis trop
content je me dis demain je vais
être lu qing de l'école c'est sûr à la
cantine tout le monde à me filer sa
portion frites il est 11 heures 50 c'est
la récréation je force pour ouvrir le
sachet et là ça tourne très très mal
en ouvrant le sachet j'me foire et tous
les jo jo zumol en dehors du sachet et
tombe à mes pieds il y avait plus de jo
jo à mes pieds que y'avait de bonbons la
fois où j'ai pété le bocal là je me sens
pas bien du tout je me dis ça se
trouve y en a un qui a roulé à l'autre
bout de l'école je retrouverai jamais et
comme par hasard ça va être un brillant
ce qui se passe c'est pire que ça mec
[Musique]
tous les élèves de la cour se retourne
vers moi un à un ils ont tous la même
idée au même moment au même endroit
courir pour me voler des jo jo ayant
compris leur mauvaise intention je me
jette à terre pour ramasser le plus de
jaws possible avant qu'il me les vols
sur 80 de joe simon restait 30 sur les
il me restait 0 jojoy rares deuxième
moment de ma vie où je me suis senti
très très mal humilié c'était le même
sentiment que quand avec ta meuf depuis
dix ans et tu te sépares à 6,6 quand
j'étais petit j'étais hyper fan de
laurie de ta meilleure amie de sur un
air latino de je vais vite
ma mère m'avait acheté une photo d'elle
à l'époque mon frère se moquer de moi
car il disait que j'étais amoureux de
laurie je n'étais pas amoureux de laurie
hockey et moi j'avais le sommet je
voulais trouver mon frère me respecte
donc je lui disais non je suis pas fan
de laurie je répondais ça à l'époque
mais il insistait des lucas j'insiste
acquiert une photo d'elle sous tournis
un jour il me met à l'épreuve
il me lance un challenge vous savez ce
que c'est le challenge qu'on a 10 ans ça
va pas lui car tu es vraiment pas
amoureux d'elle mais nous vous renvoyons
je suis pas un vieux mec vraiment oui il
respecte mon confrère ok alors pour le
mois en dessinant un doigt d'honneur sur
la photo de laurie à toi d'honneur mec
la violence je prends mon courage à deux
mains
et là mon frère me dit une phrase qui
restera à jamais gravé dans ma mémoire
il me dit ok bah je te crois quand même
pas j'ai fondu en larmes je pleurais de
toutes mes forces en touchant la photo
comme ça avec la paume de ma main cette
si belle photo de lorie et mon frère est
allé jouer dans la cour avec ses potes
me laissant seul moi et mon ex
quand j'étais à l'école primaire j'ai
failli me faire enlever me faire
kidnapper mais vraiment un matin je vais
seul à l'école primaire comme d'hab
j'avais passé là je ma mère m'emmenait
fall membre des x mais bon elle m'avait
après il ya les soldats à dire non aux
inconnus sur m'approcher etc
mais elle a fait son travail de maire à
la perfection sur ça c'est à dire que
j'étais pas naïf je marche sur le chemin
de l'école je me dis on va apprendre des
maths c'est cool ça me gratte un peu
l'oreille on verra ça en fin de journée
c'est compris puisque le jeu marche sur
le trottoir et une voiture se met à
rouler à ma vitesse juste à côté de moi
la porte arrière s'ouvre et un mec
maudit la phrase la plus cliché du monde
alors gamin tu vas à l'école en
s'énervant l'école tu peux pas venir
avec moi plutôt on va s'amuser j'ai
plein de jouer chez moi et regarde jerem
des poumons je sais que vous vous dites
que c'est trop cliché et glauque pour
être vrai mais c'est vrai je m'en
souviens très bien ça m'a traumatisé
donc là comme un enfant de 8 ans je me
chivres littéralement dessus quoi il ya
une meuf qui arrive en face de moi avec
une poussette et en voyant la poussait
je me dis ok elle est maman
ben j'ai fait un jour que c'est ma maman
à moi et du coup j'ai couru vers cette
femme que je connaissais pas en disant
maman maman il ya un monsieur qui me
proposent des bonbons et dans sa voiture
il a fallu qu'une seconde à la femme
pour comprendre et elle a regardé le mec
dans la voiture et là le mec a fermé la
porte et il a tapé un
et la maman m'a dit ça vaille terriens
fait tu veux je te ramène chez toi et je
lui ai dit non non je vais à l'école
les études avant tout je veux offrir un
bel avenir à ma famille l'enfant trop
intellectuel j'ai dit non je voulais
aller à l'école primaire et oublie ce
qui venait de se passer donc j'ai chialé
sur le chemin je serai à l'école
primaire et voilà ce cliché du mec qui
propose des bonbons à des enfants pour
les enlever ça existe vraiment et si ta
mère ta pas sensibilisé des dizaines
voire des centaines de fois vis-à-vis de
ça va tu te rends pas compte de la
situation et tu rejoins le mec dans sa
voiture quoi tu imagines est le premier
youtuber gaming ce serait un mix haine
c'est chiant quand même je t'aime à bxl
on était fan de pistolet à billes quand
on était petit et avec mon frère on
était posée dans le salon il y avait
plus mamia plus rien on se faisait chier
on devait attendre et on avait juste un
gun habits pour nous occuper et j'ai
lancé un pari à mon freinage de et dit
florent caisse quelqu'un tu vois
l'abbaye par terre à l'autre bout de la
pièce
ouais si tu arrives à la touche et en
tirant dessus eh ben je sache est ce que
tu veux tu as le droit un chargeur pas
plus donc 13 bis mon frère il se prend
pour rick de rothschild am il fait ok et
gamma je m'en occupe
mais fais moi la promesse de m'offrir
une gibson sg standard si j'y arrive je
le dis oui il tire tout be a bee ware la
vie tout ce sang est insupportable il
tira dernière be et il touche l'autre
bic était à 4 mètres de nous par terre
mon frère me regarde et la chape audric
sur la tête d'un couche pas ce qui s'est
passé tu me love quand tu veux mais
avant notre mort après ça chaque année
on a parlé au moins trois fois de ce
pari parce que ça nous faisait trop rire
c'était tellement improbable et il ya
deux ans grâce à l'argent que je gagne
grâce à youtube grâce à vous j'ai pu lui
faire la surprise de lui offrir une
gibson sg standard et voit les avis
avant de cette vidéo sur grange était
enfant à l'école primaire je pense que
j'appellerais comme ça moi là n'hésitez
pas à aller mais ça vous a plu
moi ça me fait toujours marrer de
raconter les trucs comme ça qu'ils m'ont
vraiment marqué y en a pas beaucoup je
pense que là vraiment avec ces trois
vidéos on a un peu fait le tour
n'hésitez pas à me dire vous si vous
avez vécu un truc un peu ou fait un peu
milliards ou quoi quand vous étiez jeune
mais inventer pas un truc pour faire
l'intéressant c'est chiant franchement
sur net ya trop de ça et c'est un peu
énervant je vous dis merci je vous
adresse deux prochaines vidéos portez
vous bien et surtout n'oubliez pas dit
toujours non quand un inconnu vous
propose un bonbon
[Musique]